[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bring in chris mannix sports illustrated
senior nba writer how did this deal
finally get done between the nets and
the sixers i think a lot of it dan had
to do
with the amount of public pressure that
james harden and the people around him
put on the nets in the 24 hours before
the deadline i mean i i had written for
something that went up on wednesday
morning the nets
had no intention of trading james hard
no traction on any kind of deal with
philadelphia regarding a deal with james
harden but when it started to get out
that james harden wanted to be a 76er uh
it just put sean marks between a rock
and a hard place he could hold on to
james harden and hope that the return of
kevin durant cures the
massive problems that are going on right
now in brooklyn but he probably know
that james harden was likely to walk for
nothing at the end of the year or does
he cut his losses and get the best deal
possible and look he got a great deal
like this is an excellent package that
the nets got for james harden
yeah i agree i you know i like the ben
simmons ceiling and uh the change of
scenery there now we were sensitive to
his mental health issues he couldn't
play or didn't want to play but
is it fair to question where is that or
what is that mental health situation for
him does he play right away for the uh
the nets
yeah i i don't get the sense he's going
to play
right away he will be in uniform before
the end of the season probably within
the next three or four weeks um there's
gonna have to be a ramp up period for
him i'm told physically he has not been
involved in really anything the sixers
have done uh during their practice time
so he's got to get in game shape first
and foremost and once that happens i i
do think you'll see ben simmons back of
the mix and look
it's hard to
to kind of sit here and
question his mental health and if that
was a strategy or was it like a real
thing it's just it's really hard to do
something like that all i know is that
um you know everyone simmons is camp the
nets are expecting him within the next
few weeks to make his debut for the nets
but also you have a game where the nets
play the sixers i think in philadelphia
march 10th i'm gonna guess
ben simmons will not be making that trip
to philadelphia i i really hope he does
because i will and that's that's going
to be if ben simmons plays in that game
that's as close to a must-see regular
season game as you're going to get in
the nba the reaction
from the philadelphia faithful boy it's
probably you know the worst
atmosphere i've seen for a road player
was lebron going back to cleveland in
2010 after he left the first time uh
from uh from the cavs that was
i mean there were like batteries being
tossed around in that arena at that time
i don't i was gonna say it may not get
that bad affiliate might um but it's
going to be if ben when ben simmons goes
back there
really nasty for him and maybe not so
nasty with james harden but he won't
exactly be getting a welcome reception
in brooklyn either
i i'm trying to look at this from
philadelphia's perspective getting james
harden
and
i i you know i start with joelle embiid
who might be the mvp this year now
you're bringing in a ball dominant guard
how does this work out for philadelphia
well look daryl mori's
basketball philosophies have often
centered around let's get stars like
stars win championships he had that
mindset down in houston when he first
acquired james harden and he added chris
paul then it was russell westbrook you
know none of it seemed to work but he
believes
in that ethos when it comes to building
a basketball team but it's very fair
to question how this works now
you know scouts will tell me like how do
you guard them in the pick and roll like
they're going to be unstoppable when you
go harden and bead pick and roll you
can't switch you go under hard and make
shots it's it's a very difficult thing
to do but their defense is going to take
a hit harden is not a good defensive
player tyrese maxi who has had a
tremendous second season filling in for
ben simmons he's probably going to have
an adjustment period trying to figure
out how he a ball-handling guy is going
to play next to harden who as you said
likes to have the ball in his hands a
lot look daryl got his man here in james
harden and deserves all the credit in
the world
for doing that but at the same time
it is fair to question if what daryl
wants is the right thing like would this
team
have not benefited from maybe looking
down to atlanta and gotten a package
that included a john collins or a bug on
bug donovic and multiple draft picks
back in return i saw my old friend bobby
marks on espn used to work for the nets
for years he said something on tv that
that rings completely true uh you know
the nets are gonna or the sixers are
gonna give james harden a contract
that's going to be around 270 million
dollars over the next five years and
bobby called it in three years the worst
contract in nba history without even
seeing what james harden is it's going
to be the worst contract in nba history
because at age 36 37 38 he's gonna be
making well north of 50 million dollars
so what the sixers did
is that they created like a two maybe
three year
championship window and that is assuming
the health and success of embiid and
james harden we're talking to chris
mannix he covers the nba for sports
illustrated
uh i guess let's look at the hierarchy
in the east after the trade the the team
to beat is
who
still milwaukee i mean the bucks just
keep cruising along i mean they
you know made some minor deal you know
getting serge ibaka you know they're not
getting the 2019 serge ibak he's had a
lot of health issues in the last couple
of years but you know it's brook lopez
insurance in case lopez can't play this
year but you watch that team dan they're
just i mean they're just cruising they
crushed the lakers the other night
they've been beating up on a lot of
teams
this year they're going into the
playoffs with enormous confidence so to
me it's milwaukee at the top and kind of
everybody else including miami chicago
brooklyn philadelphia a cut below them
lakers couldn't make anything happen was
there any uh possibility that they were
going to be able to move russell
westbrook
now they they tried
everything and unsurprisingly there
wasn't much appetite for the uh taylon
horton tucker kendrick nunn kind of
poo-poo platter the lakers were sort of
throwing out there for her current offer
i mean kendrick dunn hasn't played a
minute this season and taylor horton
tucker's numbers have dipped uh from the
terrific year he had last year when it
comes to westbrook
could there have been something with
houston maybe but the lakers
made it pretty clear they weren't
willing to attach a draft pick that 2027
first
to russell westbrook just to get rid of
it like they they know it's not working
they're very aware of that there but
they've surrendered so much draft
capital over the last few years dan in
the anthony davis deal and the russell
westbrook deal they just couldn't
stomach giving away
another draft pick uh down the line so
there really wasn't any traction it's i
can tell you there was a lot of
frustration
within the lakers about not being able
to do something because
after getting
you know
tattooed by milwaukee and then getting
beat by
i wouldn't even call them portland it's
like anthony simons and like the cast of
grown-ups out there that beat uh the
lakers the other night like it after
getting beat up like that they knew
something needed to change
and they didn't so right now in los
angeles what they're doing is crossing
their fingers and hoping that two or
three you know able-bodied players wind
up in the buy-out market and they can
pick them up there yeah you you start to
look at this and you handicap this for
lebron
why would lebron want to stick around
for this
you know what you know what's the like
what here here's something i i just i
wish we could give lebron truth serum in
about a month right so i think it's
march 21st
the lakers go to cleveland and
unless something changes the cavaliers
probably gonna run them off the floor
like the cavs are really good you know
garland's an all-star uh they make some
moves around the trade deadline to get
carousel avert jared allen's still
pissed off on not being an all-star i
mean kevin love is like the sixth man of
the year or at least one of them like
what is going to go through lebron's
mind as he's kind of dragging the lakers
along and they go into cleveland and
that team is is beating up on them like
in front of that crowd which is going to
be wild on that night if the lakers are
struggling and the cavs are playing well
so i
i i don't know what his his options are
at this point the lakers don't have many
options at this point to get measurably
better uh but you know he knows what
this team is and it's not very good
if he could swap supporting cass right
now
and go to cleveland
i mean i i don't know but how how
couldn't you like like the cabs are fun
like they're they they can they scored
they played defense i mean isaac akkoro
was good as a as a as a rotation player
i mentioned al evan mobley evan mobley's
like you're looking at anthony davis 10
years ago like it's like you you've got
all the pieces there they're incredibly
athletic
and look they might be quite frankly dan
they might be like a small forward away
from being like a dynasty you know
they're playing lowry marganin at the
three like you plug lebron into that mix
and all of a sudden you've got like a
team that should win two or three
championships so it's i it's gonna be i
mean they're that good like they're i
mean they keep losing guys like ricky
rubio is a huge part
i hope you're doing well ricky just not
a much love but he's he he goes down and
they just plug somebody else in they
acquire rajon rondo they acquired carris
levert you know kobe altman to his
credit to gm there just pushing all his
chips into the table on this season to
see if they can do something special did
you make your bed
uh
no okay
you knew you were going to be on tv
though i was i was working late last
night dan and i got up 10 minutes ago to
talk to you yeah no i'm just curious if
you made your bed like it's it's made
adjacent it's kind of like tossed you
throw the sheet over it okay
all right
uh well it's great to talk to you
good to talk to you dad let's do it
again chris thank you
absolutely that's chris manning sports
illustrated senior nba writer